salut
[Musique]
ce type était déjà inconscient moi
j'étais déjà prêt à le frapper j'aurais
peut-être pas dû le faire bon bah tant
pis
salut
[Musique]
chef celui-là il est pas endormi
[Applaudissements]
je viens vous sortir de là
pourquoi vous êtes aussi beau mon père
était dans un boys band
es
vous êtes obligés de passer par là pour
la sauver je crois que par là elle va
bien non non
poursuivre
pourquoi tu continues à faire ça
pourquoi vous vous continuez j'allais le
dégommer mais c'est pas bien et c'est
inutile désolé en avoir au moins
excusez-moi c'est possible de me libérer
de ce
fauteuil
[Musique]
pourquoi toutes ces explosions
vous êtes sauvés maintenant tu es comme
comment pouvez-vous rester aussi calme
c'était ma réplique ça attendez
que ça va me calmer je pense
comme le dit là au-dessus lorsque
l'esprit connaît la tranquillité
l'univers tout entier maîtriser
on devrait peut-être pas rester là à se
regarder les yeux dans les yeux comme si
on tombait amoureux et faire comme comme
si j'étais pas là
tu pourrais me sortir du fauteuil
c'est une Lima ongles ça non et si tu
l'arrachais simplement
et puis tu pourrais même me le dire
avant de la Lancer
synonyme
dans le langage courant tu dis
on voit un sweat-shirt tu dis je
t'envoie un stylo bille si tu avais dit
attrape ce flingue tout ce que tu
voudras m'envoyer je l'attraperai parce
que tu auras dit attrape et je
l'attraperai parce que tu leur dis bon
dis ça je dis rien il faudrait encore
qu'on ait un flingue avec nous c'est ça
le problème
fais attention ok il faut téléphoner
il faut appeler les secours aller à
l'aéroport nous enfer d'ici et c'est moi
qui conduit
[Musique]
allez appelle les secours vas-y appelle
ton téléphone
dites-moi que vous les avez coincés
qu'est-ce que vous imaginez vous avez
tué l'un d'entre eux mais son acolyte
est encore avec elle et on voit qu'il
est très très doué on ne peut plus
entraîner et extrêmement dangereux
des chaussures c'est pas l'idéal pour
l'escalade c'est toi qui me les a
apporté
je peux pas aller plus loin je peux pas
aller plus loin je me sens pas bien là
vas-y je sais que tu te crois en
sécurité en restant accroché mais il
faut que tu continues
bravo d'accord c'était de la
manipulation merci
super désolé pour mes cheveux qui
doivent rater
[Musique]
non rien c'est quelque chose que John et
moi on disait quand on avait fini une
chose importante comme une fouille
archéologique ou un manuscrit c'est du
latin qui signifie plus d'eau après les
difficultés
comment on dit en latin l'aurait été une
vraie badasse
faire
t'inquiète pas pour elle elle a dû
mobiliser toute la marine pour nous
je comprends que
tu retires super actif je viens de
Twitter est-ce qu'on ma kidnappé
#dm@hotmendes
seul
célibataire alors ça pourra marcher ok
racontez-moi vous allez à New York de là
vous partez en Guinée ou vous allez
pouvoir prendre un sauteur de FLAC
un petit avion c'est bon c'est bon je le
prends je le prends
il nous faut quelque chose de plus
inflammable tout ça est trop humide il y
a quoi là-dedans il y a quoi dans ton
sacs
de beauté
elle m'a fait un cadeau bizarre pour la
fête des mères t'offre des cadeaux pour
la fête des mères
oui j'ai fait du feu
c'est plutôt impressionnant